Okay. I want to sort of do a reset of 2019
for the David Pakman show. And then maybe
more importantly, I want to hear from you
about what you want from us in 2020 really
important, uh, stuff, particularly when there
are so many forces working against independent
media.
In many ways. 2019 was an awesome year for
the David Pakman show. A few numbers for you.
Podcast downloads. We're up 71% 2019 over
2018 is 71% an incredible number. YouTube
views were up 29% we had 93 million views
in 2018 up to 121 million views in 2019 very
solid YouTube subscribers, notably up 88%
we started 2019 with 418,000 subscribers and
we ended 2019 with 789,000 subscribers a big,
big year as far as YouTube subscriptions go.
Also paid memberships up 86% I set a couple
of weeks ago when that, uh, racist Kansas
troll called in and said, David, your membership
program is an embarrassment. It's just not
going to work. It's not happening. Paid memberships
membership started in 2010 okay, so we had
2010 2011 2012 2013 you get the point during
2019 almost doubling paid memberships up 86%
now it's not all ginger snaps and waterfalls,
areas of difficulty. You continue to be the
monetization of our content on various platforms.
YouTube being a a a top one. So my question
to you is what do you want in 2020 do you
want more international politics? Do you want
more live streams of special events the way
we did over the last couple of months with
impeachment hearings and debates, so on and
so forth. Are you interested in more long
form pieces? If so, what subjects are interesting
to you? Is there a particular type of election
coverage that you do want or you don't want?
How often should we be talking about polling?
For example, how often should we be talking
about whatever I want to hear from you about
this. Do you want the show canceled altogether?
Do you want me to quit and turn the show over
to producer Pat? It will be the David Pakman
show no longer hosted by David Pakman. Are
you interested in us coming to you from primary
States on election days last year or last
election?
For example, on primary day in 2016 in New
Hampshire, we were talking to voters in, was
it Manchester or Keene? I don't even remember.
I must've been Manchester. I don't remember
where I was, but it was, that's something
that we are looking at doing. So the show
has always been guided and directed by the
audience. So I want to hear from you. What
are you interested in seeing for 2020? What
do you think will provide value? What do you
think will be useful in that other media outlets
are not doing it? And if you don't want anything
to change, don't worry. The show will remain
the show. I always want to iterate, see what
we can do better, see what we can tweak. But
the show will basically remain the David Pakman
show. One last question on this. Are there
other platforms you believe the David Pakman
show should be on?
Um, we get a lot of invitations to put the
show on new platforms and I will test some
out and some don't work out. A notably Jordan
Peterson's think spot is one that did not
work out for us in 2019 there is a new platform
that we're on that is actually really exciting.
It's called a library. It's L B R Y. Dot TV.
We've quietly added our back catalog and new
content to library. I've not been promoting
it yet. We've picked up about 1100 subscribers
so far. It looks like it has legs. It's a
very cool platform where people leave tips
in an on platform currency called LBC tokens.
It works really well on like a lot of these
platforms. There's a link in the video description.
If you're watching this on YouTube, you can
also just go to LBR Y. Dot. TV. You can either
download the desktop application or you can
just access the content on the website itself.
Um, it's a very, very cool platform. We will
be posting all of our content there in 2020
and I will probably have a more to say about
it upcoming. So let me know. Should we be
on new platforms stuff you want us to add
stuff you want us to take away? Everything's
fine. Just keep doing what we're doing. Always
welcome a suggestions. Send me a tweet at
D Pacman or a, shoot me an email. Go to David
pakman.com and use our contact form. Uh, we'd
love to hear from you.